when we die the greatest regret that
people typically have on their deaths by
the state or I wish I had spent more
time on Twitter
no I don't think that's the case I think
I was probably uh have spent less time
on Twitter but I found it so useful for
myself and also so addictive that I felt
I need to make the best of it and turn
it into an art form and thought form and
it did help me to develop something yeah
but I wish uh what other things I could
have done in the meantime it's just not
the universe that we are in anymore most
people don't read books anymore
what do you think that means that we
don't read books anymore what do you
think that means about the collective
intelligence of our species is it
possible it's still progressing and
growing or experience there is stuff
happening on Twitter that was impossible
for Spokes and I really regret that
um Twitter has not taken the turn that I
was hoping for I thought Elon is global
brainpilled and understands that this
thing needs to self-organize and he
needs to develop tools to allow the
profligation of the self-organization so
Twitter can become sentient and maybe
this was a pipe dream from the beginning
but I felt that the enormous pressure
that he was under made it impossible for
him to work on any kind of content goals
and uh also many of the decisions that
he made under this pressure seemed to be
not very wise I don't think that as a
CEO of a social media company you should
have opinions in the cultural bar in
public I think that's very short-sighted
and it's I also suspect that it's not a
good idea to
um
gram of all people yeah um over setting
a mastodon link and I think Paul made
this uh intentionally because he wanted
to show Elon Musk that blocking people
for setting a link is completely counter
to any idea of free speech that he
intended to bring to Twitter and
basically seeing that
um Elon was way less principled in his
thinking there and is much more
experimental and many of the things that
he is trying
um
they pan out very differently in Digital
Society than they pen out in a car
company because the effect is very
different because everything that you do
in a digital Society is going to have
real world cultural effects
and so basically I find it quite
regrettable that this guy is
able to become de facto the pope but
Twitter has more active members than the
Catholic church and he doesn't get it
the power and responsibility that he has
and the ability to create something in a
society that is lasting and that is
producing a digital Agora in a way that
has never existed before where we build
a social network on top of a social
network an actual Society on top of the
algorithms
so this is something that just hopes
still in the future and still in the
cards but um
it's something that exists in small
parts I find that the corner of Twitter
that I'm in is extremely Pleasant it's
just you know take a few steps outside
of it is not very wholesome anymore and
the way in which people interact with
strangers suggest that it's not a
civilized society yet
so as your as the number of people who
follow you on Twitter expands
you feel the burden
of the uglier sides of humanity yes but
there's also a similar thing in uh in
the normal world that is if you become
more influential if you have more status
if you have more Fame in the real world
you have uh you get lots of perks but
you also uh have way less freedom in the
way in which you interact with people
especially with strangers because
a certain percentage of people it's a
small single digit perspective
percentage is nuts and dangerous and uh
the more of those are looking at you the
more of them might get ideas but what if
the technology enables you to discover
the majority of people to discover and
connect efficiently and regularly with
the majority of people who are actually
really good I mean one of my
sort of concerns with the platform my
Twitter is
there's a lot of really smart people out
there a lot of smart people that
disagree with me and with others between
each other and I love that if the
technology would bring those to the top
the beautiful disagreements like uh
intelligent squared type of debates
there's a bunch of I mean one of my
favorite things to listen to is
arguments and arguments like high effort
arguments with the respect and love
underneath it but then it gets a little
too heated but that kind of too heated
which I've seen you participate in and I
love that uh with Lee Corona with those
kinds of folks and you go pretty hard
like you get frustrated but it's all
beautiful obviously I can't do this
because uh we know each other yes and
Lee is has the rare gift of being
willing to be wrong in public Yeah so
basically he has thoughts that are as
wrong as the random thoughts of an
average highly intelligent person but he
blurts them out while not being sure if
they're right and he enjoys doing that
and once you understand that this is his
game you don't get offended by him
saying something that you think is so
wrong but he's constantly passively
communicating a respect for the people
he's talking with and for just basic
humanity and truth and all that kind of
stuff and there's a self-deprecating
thing there's a bunch of like social
skills you acquire that allow you to be
a great debater a great argumenter like
be wrong in public and explore ideas
together in public when you disagree and
if I would love for Twitter to elevate
those folks Elevate those kinds of
conversations it already does in some
sense but uh also if it elevates them
too much then you get this phenomenon
Clubhouse where you always get dragged
on stage and I found this very stressful
because it was too intense yeah and I
don't like to be dragged on stage all
the time yeah I think once a week is
enough and also when I met Lee the first
time I found that a lot of people seem
to be shocked by the fact that he was uh
being very aggressive as their results
that he didn't seem to show a lot of
sensibility in in a way in which he was
criticizing what they were doing and
being dismissive of the work of others
and uh that was not I think in any way a
shortcoming of him because I noticed
that he was much much more dismissive
with respect of his own work it was his
General stance and I felt that this
General stance is creating a lot of
liability for him because really a lot
of people take offense at him being not
like their Carnegie character who is
always smooth and make sure that
everybody likes them so I really respect
that he is willing to take that risk and
to be wrong in public and to offend
people and he doesn't do this in in any
bad way it's just most people fear or
not all people recognize this and so I
can be much more aggressive with him
than it can be with many other people
who don't play the same game because he
understands the way in the spirit in
which I respond to him I think that's
the fun and it's a beautiful game it's
ultimately a productive one